So this is pretty much the spread for all four quarters.
We're excited.
Yeah.
I've gotta tell you, this is very aggressive for...
You think?
...what we're trying to do.
Yeah, you know, we had a tough quarter.
Right, I understand.
Now we're trying to amortize it from here to here.
You know, the thing is I like it,...
Right.
...I just don't love it.
Sure, sure, sure.
I understand.
Hey, by the way, it's good to see you.
It's been a while, right?
Long time, yeah.
How is Maureen?
She's good.
She took the kids up to the mountains for the week.
Nice. Camping?
Car camping.
Is there any other kind?
Apparently not.
Yeah. And Chris likes Saint Matthew's?
Yeah, he loves it.
Well, great school.
Yeah, I know, he's having a good time.
Let me ask you.
Did you finally get rid of that rash?
Yeah, it's clearing up.
Good, good, good, good.
Speaking of clearing up, let me clear up some of these numbers here for you.
I'm listening.
I think you will find that the bottom line makes a lot of sense.
Now it does.